ثلاثيه الصراع الدام والمرض والجوع في
السودان كم من روح ستزهق حتى ينجلي ليل
ماسي هذا البلد
الانتظار الطويل جدا والمر من اجل شراء
الخبز من رفاهيه ساعه الهدنه الهشه والمحل
النادره التي ما تزال مفتوحه في الخرطوم
تمت احياء اختفى فيها الخبز والماء
والكهرباء تماما السودان الكبير بمساحته
وتاريخه داخل اتون حرب عبثيه وعلى شفير
مجاعه كبرى وكارثه انسانيه معديه لدول
الجوار يقول المواطنون ان الازمه المعيشيه
بدات منذ اليوم الاول للاقتتال المفتوح
على اسوا السيناريوهات والنهايات باللغه
الارقام الاوليه المجاعه ليست شبحا بل
حقيقه موجعه يتجرعها الشعب في الخرطوم
ودارفور والولايات التي هرب اليها الالاف
بحثا عن الامان مثل الجزيره والنيل الازرق
وشمال
من الاسواق في الخرطوم اغلقت خشيه اعمال
النهب ارتفعت اسعار السلع الاساسيه ما بين
3400 في المئه في بعض الاحيان الرفوف
الفارغه في المحل ستبقى كذلك الى اشعار
اخر تعطلت المصانع وتوقفت حركه الاستيراد
برا وبحرا وجوا تجار الازمات يعيشون عزهم
على ماس الاخرين الجسور المغلقه قطعت طرق
الامداد الى الخرطوم التي تعاني نقصا حادا
في كل شيء نعد الرصاص ما في ما في موارد
ما في موارد ما في اي حاجه بضاعه جديده
خاصه ما في دقيق بيجي ما في حاجه ولا اي
شيء اي حاجه قطعت ثاني ما بتكون فيه
باعتراف الامين العام للامم المتحده
انطونيو كل التقارير القادمه من السودان
ترسم صوره قادمه لعالقنا داخل المنازل
ونقص في امدادات الغذاء والماء والادويه
يستمر النجاح في عمليات اجلاء الاجانب من
السودان ومعه فشل المجتمع الدولي في ايصال
المساعدات الانسانيه الى بلد كان في زمن
السلام يعتمد ثلث سكانه على معاناه منظمه
الاغذيه العالميه هذه الصور بست في مايو
العام الماضي بمناسبه تحذير الامم المتحده
من مجاعه تهدد السودان
كيف سيكون الوضع الان بعد انعدام الامن
لدرجه اغلاق السفارات واخلاق البلد من كل
اجنبي يمكنه النجاه من هذا الجحيم ماذا عن
السودانيين القطاع الصحي ليس بخير ووضعه
حرج للغايه كثره التحذيرات من المنظمات
العالميه وتعذرت الحلول لانعاش ما بقي من
مؤسسه طبيه تفيد منظمه الصحه العالميه ان
اكثر من 60% من المنشات الصحيه في الخرطوم
مغلقه وبان 16% فقط تعمل بشكل طبيعي علاج
ما يقدر بنحو 50 الف طفل يعانون سوء
التغذيه غير متاح بسبب دوامه العنف
الحاليه من يحرم السودانيين من امنهم
السياسي والغذائي والصحي من سرق مرحله كان
يفترض ان تنقله الى المدنيه التي صار من
اجلها قبل السنوات توقع كل شيء ما عدا ان
يستيقظ على حرب تندلع في الخرطوم وتمتد
السنتها الحارقه الى دارفور وغيرها من
المناطق حرب تقتل وتجوع وتهجر وتدمر سدانا
ليس به مكان لكل هذا الوجع